so i've been looking to having this
conversation for a couple months and it
was just sitting on the schedule and i
kept looking forward to it
and i found myself you know a couple
minutes into the phone call
and i said hey just out of curiosity how
much are your companies doing a year in
revenue right now
he said well i think we're doing over a
billion dollars a year now
and that's when i was like man i have a
lot to learn from this guy
so hi my name is alex romosi i'm the
owner of
and ceo of allen gym launch prestige
labs and five other portfolio companies
and i have absolutely nothing to sell
you
you know there's a lot of people out
there who struggle to make money and are
struggling to you know grow their net
worth and i made this channel to make
sure that you are not one of them
what i want to share with you is some of
the kind of excerpts or the private
conversations that i had
with a man doing a billion dollars here
in revenue that's privately held so his
company or companies are privately held
he owns um
50 of them and uh he's probably in his
mid 70s
for the security of that individual i'm
not going to reveal his identity but
what i will do
is give you all the lessons that i wrote
down as a result of this conversation
all right
the first thing that i think before i
even get into it that i'm going to get
asked from this video is like well how
do you get access
to guys like that and um further along
this video i'll explain
how he went from 100 million dollars to
a billion dollars a year in revenue
his process around that i also talked
about how he organized his personnel
and did his incentive programs uh where
he was allocating his capital
that he felt he got the best returns
from so jam-packed lots of good stuff
for you from a man who has done it and
lived it
and so the first one is about how do you
get access to something like this and so
one of the things that i think i hear on
like the entrepreneur channels and
things that i cruise around and snoop
around down is i hear these big mass
market people say like
just go buy a millionaire a lunch or
just say you'll go work with a
millionaire for free
um i don't think that's realistic
because you have nothing to offer that
person
and so i think the first step is
self-awareness of understanding that
like you only have x amount of value now
your
intention should be to increase that
value you have in the achievements that
you have
so that you can gain access to higher
level people so now
i've gotten to the point of my career
where you know he knows that we're doing
just under 100 million a year
and so i had real questions that i
wanted to ask him and the person who
made the introduction was like hey this
guy's legit
you know he he loves all your all your
content and all your books and things
like that could you
would you know would you mind helping
him out or taking a call and so he
agreed which was crazy for me and i was
really really thrilled about it but
you know if doesn't matter where you're
at you can probably just add
you know a zero or multiply whatever
you're doing by five
and that's probably around where
somebody where your cutoff might be so
if you're making a hundred thousand
dollars a year
then you know gaining access to somebody
making a million dollars a year is
probably around where the cutoff is
going to be for what your
you know achievements will give you
access to and that's kind of the
the reason that i think a lot of these
coaching programs and masterminds and
things like that exist
is because people can't gain access to
that level of person
uh without some sort of you know prior
achievement and if you haven't achieved
it then you have to compensate that
that person with money in some way right
we got on the phone call
and this was layla and i am playlist my
wife she runs these companies with me
she's co-ceo she actually just started a
youtube channel if you want to check
that out
but the the first thing that i asked him
was i said hey ben
uh i had been stuck at you know mid 30
million dollars a year
uh between 30 and 40 for three years and
you know
i just from listening to some of the
stuff that you had really understood the
breakthrough of how to get to 100 and
right now
we're pacing probably about 85 but i
think that that breakthrough
was was key which was understanding to
focus on people now you might be like
well duh i have heard that everywhere
alex why are you so
dumb great question i think that what i
did not understand
was that as the entrepreneur we believe
that we are source of everything
and at a certain point there's only so
much influence that you can have and
maybe i'm just not influential enough
that's that's possible right
but your ability to influence people one
level two level three level four levels
of management below where you're at you
know dilutes over time like you are
potent
but you become disseminated as levels of
manage and get introduced which is
natural when you whenever
you grow an organization right the first
thing that he said that i thought was
really powerful was understanding what
levels of talent exist
and so he said there's really just stars
and superstars and
one of the things that he said
completely shifted my perspective about
how to view those things
and i'll tell you what that was in a
second but the key point that he said is
that every business that is going to
grow and be self-sustaining must have
three superstars
and i was like huh that's really
interesting and where he divided the
superstars out was actually exactly
where
i would have divided them out as well
which was you need to have somebody
who's in charge of acquisition
you have someone who's in charge of
delivery and someone who's in charge of
operations and shared shared services
right
that means one person gets new clients
one person delivers on promises
and the third person keeps the first two
out of jail by making sure that bills
are paid and
and payroll happens and legal and i.t
and all the lovely things that come with
running a business that no one ever
thinks about
he was like if you have three superstars
then that business can grow
on its own the second thing um
was layering on the incentive packages
appropriately and this is something that
you know charlie munger warren buffett
you know and this guy
i feel like i see this common theme
around the guys who make the most money
in the world is that they are not afraid
to give up a little bit of the pie
to make more people wealthy so that the
pie itself can grow
it's easy to say it's hard to do and i
think one of the biggest mistakes that i
made for the vast majority of my early
business career was not understanding
how to align incentives and you know i
think charlie munger says like show me
the incentives and i'll show you the
outcomes
and so when i started out in my career i
thought that i just had to partner with
everyone and that wasn't the right call
for me at the time because i ended up
partnering with people who had the same
skill sets as me because they seemed
cool and we like the same things
but the reality is that i should have
been partnering with people if i was
going to partner
uh with people who had different skill
sets so i might have been the
acquisition guy because that's probably
i would say my my skill set but i should
have partnered with somebody who was
really good at delivery service
product etc and had somebody who really
owned the operational you know portion
of the business
and so that's what i should have thought
of now mind you i had a mentor early on
in that time in my life who said listen
you might need an accountant it doesn't
mean that you have to give them equity
in your company right you just pay them
as a vendor
and that was again something that i did
not understand when i was earlier on and
so just if you're starting out your
career
you know you don't need to give away
equity in your company to get things
done
you can just pay for them and that's
okay in fact it's encouraged because the
most expensive
equity you typically give away is in the
beginning
and so being mindful of that and
leveling up your skill sets so that you
don't have to
i think a lot of times can yield
disproportionate returns and in the
companies that i have grown to you know
eight figures multiple figures and now
knocking on nine have come from
companies that i that i own
right and have very small percentage of
equity that i allocate to people who are
star performers
which leads me to one of the things that
he talked about
that i referenced earlier which is
understanding the difference between
superstars and stars
and so um he said something that really
stuck with me
and after this i'll tell you what he
said about how he allocates his money
and whatnot because i think that was
really cool
but how he identifies superstars he said
listen you we all want superstars right
and we know him when we see him
but what i have noticed is that i've
never
not thought someone was a superstar and
then later realized they were
he said now i've had people who came in
and i thought they were superstars and
then they
they it turned out they weren't
superstars but i've never had the
reverse happen where someone comes in i
don't think they're a star or a
superstar
and then they become one and so i took
that as a key learning for myself which
is once we're bringing in high level
talent we're bringing in leaders we're
bringing in
drivers that if we don't immediately
think that they're a superstar then it
means that they're probably not a fit
for that role
and that can be hard because one of the
biggest things that gets in the way of
excellent is good enough
i can tell you as somebody who's hired
so many good enough people
and i think later now hired true
superstars
the difference is is is uncanny it's
night and day that they're able to
solve problems bring solutions to the
table and implement them
without your input oftentimes what you
know you have to end up doing which is
why the gap between 30 to 100 million
is about giving up the next level of
control which is kind of the
control around high level decisions
right you have to give people the
autonomy and the power because a
superstar wants that kind of power right
they want that kind of authority they
want that responsibility and they want
they want the responsibility because
they want the credit for
the outcome right and so this was
something that took me a long time to
understand and
the way that he incentivized those
people that he shared with me and i will
share with you right now so you guys
don't have to
get a billion dollar a year you know
entrepreneur on the phone is he said
he would set up profit shares for those
ceos and he only did it for the ceos of
his companies
he had so many beliefs i'll share one of
them with you right now he said i don't
believe that businesses should make a
profit
and so this man is clearly a philosopher
at this point in his career just fyi the
guy's
mid-70s peaceful as can be salt of the
earth
and i was like i don't even know what
that means he said i said can you
clarify that he said
i believe that profits are unnatural he
said i don't think that they're
naturally occurring i think that a
business
if left on its you know lift to its own
devices will pretty much break even
and i thought about that and i thought
and i thought more and i thought more
about it i was like i guess that's true
he's like it's unnatural to create
profits
and it takes willpower to create profits
because you have to create outsized
returns compared to the marketplace
because everyone else
most of the time is the same resources
as you do or you know they have the same
24 hours they've
many times the same access to skill and
talent that you do and so if you have
the same access skill and talent you
know and you have the same resources or
similar resources then
then how is it that you're going to
out-compete them it takes something
unnatural it takes something
above and beyond and so for him he
believed that creating profits is a
natural and is the sole responsibility
of the ceo which i thought was
interesting i'm not sorry 100 agree it
might not
i just might not be at that level yet i
don't know um but he said he shared
five percent of profits with those uh
entrepreneurs and he also
gave them the opportunity to buy in
truly buy-in not just like giving equity
but
buy in bigger and bigger chunks of the
company he said i think one of his
biggest companies
that he has the ceo owns like 30
something percent of that company now
and started at 5 or 10.
and so the reason i'm sharing this is
that like at a certain point
the company becomes a conglomeration of
companies of
of drivers who are driving growth across
channels
right across individual profit centers
that all roll into one larger
conglomerate and so just just
fundamentally shifting my understanding
of like
what business will become instead of
like oh i'm going to sell
you know a hundred doors now i'm gonna
sell a thousand dollars and i'm gonna
sell ten thousand dollars right
and i say door it could be pens or ball
caps or it doesn't really matter but the
point is is that we're selling a widget
of some sort right
instead it's it's you might have a
business that sells
a hundred you know doorknobs and a
hundred doors and a hundred door frames
and door insurance
and all that type of stuff around and
each one of those things becomes a
profit center
for the overarching conglomerate and has
a driver who has specialization within
that industry and has done it before
and so i think when he shared this to me
like
it reinforced one of my core beliefs
which is advanced people
are advanced because they never don't do
the basics like
so many people you know myself included
i would see people on stage and they
would say what they were doing and i was
like there's no way it's that
simple but i think the reality is it is
that simple it's just not easy
finding good people is hard it's the
number one issue all businesses have
it's like because if
fundamentally every single person who's
listening to this right now is three
amazing hires away from all the growth
you've ever wanted
like think about that like we're all
three hours away
from all the growth we've ever wanted
and our time back and i feel like i'm
just beginning to really experience this
as an entrepreneur and i'll tell you
it's trippy it's weird
not being needed and i would encourage
it and i think that there were multiple
times throughout my career where i
thought
that i was not needed and i stepped away
and then things crashed
and then i had to jump back in and so
maybe you've had that experience too
but when that happens sure there's
process issues etc but
most times it's because there's a lack
of talent and i'll share
one conclusion that i made from this
thing and i'll tell you what
his investment advice was but one of the
conclusions that i have is that
the size of the corporation is directly
proportional
to the amount of superstars that are
present and so when you think i'm like
superstars i'm not talking
stars stars are great you need a players
right but who are who are the people of
that x factor that it fact that
something different
that can really drive right and as a
company gets bigger he even shared this
too he said you know you need fewer
drivers and you need superstar tenders
you need people who are not hunters but
but farmers who can just tend to the
company overall
and make the incremental improvements
because a lot of times companies grow
in a stepwise fashion so it's huge
growth plateau huge growth plateau huge
growth plateau
and then we as entrepreneurs think we're
you know breaking something when in
reality that's just oftentimes is how
growth occurs because there are
bottlenecks there are constraints
that are on the business and then you
de-bottleneck them and then you
experience the next level of growth
and usually you de-bottleneck them with
a person who has experience or who has
talent
in that specific area who can solve the
problem for you and has done it before
as promised what i'm going to do is i'm
going to wrap this puppy up with his
advice on investing and so he said
so i'm just giving you straight from the
horse's mouth this is what he told me so
he said you know we've done really well
in real estate we have a couple hundred
million dollars in real estate
and we've done it all through the
company and so he and his partner um
share share the equity in the deals that
they do
and they buy all multi-family real
estate so big buildings with lots of
apartments
he said when i buy he said i'm more
concerned on return
of capital than return on capital
so i'll say that again he said i'm more
concerned when i invest with return
of capital than return on capital and i
thought that was
it just consistently reinforces what i
keep finding with the people who are
worth so much more who are worth 500
million worth of billion dollars is that
the high risk stuff everybody who's poor
wants to buy the lottery ticket but
everyone who's rich just wants to own
the lottery game and make 10 a year on
it right
and so he said that for him he just
wants to invest in things because he
realized that he's like no matter what
he's like the tenants are paying for the
mortgage for me
he said sure you know some of them we
did better some of them we did worse
he's like but overall as long as i
thought all the fundamentals were sound
um then i was going to just have a great
store
for my wealth and he's like and sure we
lucked out a few times uh
but for me this is him saying this he's
like but for me that has been a really
uh
great vehicle and i was like okay well
jiminy rules of thumb you know just off
the top of mind of
of uh of how you pick those spots and he
says you know in general i never i never
passed
a a cap rate of eight he said so if it
was below eight i wouldn't do it
um and that's that's how he picked his
deals
and i thought that was really
interesting and so you know layla and i
have looked at that in terms of rules of
thumb for the purchases that we're
looking at and whatnot
he would rather have slightly higher
value buildings
that he thought there was less risk in
that he felt more guaranteed that his
capital would come back to him
than trying to you know maximize his
internal rate of return and i think to a
certain degree that goes with
the leverage that he might employ like
how much debt is he going to take on to
buy this facility
because if you get more debt then you're
going to get better returns but you also
increase your risk
and so coming from a man who obviously
doesn't need anything else in life
i thought that was also valuable because
i think as you as you grow as an
entrepreneur
it becomes so much more about downside
mitigation because you know adding you
know doubling your net worth doesn't
really change anything about your life
but
cutting your net worth in half does and
so it's really about like what are we
what problem are we solving what are we
trying to accomplish here and making
sure that the way that we make decisions
is aligned with that
these were uh some of the notes that i
had let me make sure oh and i'll tell
you the one last thing they told me i
said
all right so we followed your advice of
getting you know from 30 million to 100
million
this is this is really good you're going
to want to listen to this one um i said
okay well then how did you get from 100
million to a billion
and this is stuff that you will never
find anywhere all right you will not
find this anywhere written down because
there are so few billionaires
and there's so few people who are doing
a billion dollars here in revenue who
can actually share this with
with truth and his answer will crack you
up or at least it cracked me up
and so he said he said well i'll be
honest with you man he said you know
when we were
we did 100 million a year for for four
or five years
and he said and honestly we got so burnt
out because we kept wanting to go you
know wanting to grow we just couldn't
grow it anymore so we couldn't get past
100 million
he said so we pretty much just gave up
and we
we took the company we broke it into 100
little pieces and we gave
um you know profit sharing and small
equity pieces phantom equity
to our our best superstars and our
drivers and he said me and my partner
pretty much kind of checked out
he said and here's what's crazy five
years later we were at 500 million
and five years after that he said we
were at a billion and i was like
wow and i was like so so i mean what
would you what would you say
like so how do you how do you go to a
billion and he was like i think the way
you get to a billion is
not trying to get to a billion and i was
like man
like that's like it was it was that i
felt that i was like
really he said i think it was luck it's
like i think there was a lot of things
that happened and that that you know
things were aligned
a it showed the humility that the man
had but also that you know he's like
there's a couple key decisions that were
super important
uh for our development within those
companies um
and he said and i oppose them but it was
it was decisions that were made by
the leaders of the company and they did
it anyways he's like and they were right
i was wrong
and so i think it just underlined a huge
humility but the reality that for most
of us entrepreneurs like we don't have
all the answers like we have a lot of
answers but we don't have them all
and i think that seeing how he did that
going from 100 million to a billion
dollars a year and that he was like
it's luck and it was basically
incentivizing a lot of people
and he was growing the pie it was making
other people wealthy
and allowing you to participate in their
creation of their own wealth
i think that makes a lot of sense
because the drive uh i will say
personally as an entrepreneur to make
more money
after a certain point at least for me in
my current chapter has
has diminished significantly and my
desire has
has shifted far more to making things
like this
and helping other people out because i
think i think the world needs it so
anywho i think that the reason that his
company was able to grow and this is
just from my perspective is that
all these other people were getting
their kind of first nut for lack of
better term
and he was able to capitalize on them
getting their you know grow
driving so hard uh because he was able
to give them that incentive
uh to do so and so hearing him say that
was really cool for me
um and i think that for me as an
entrepreneur hearing that it was much
more like well
the way to go forward is really finding
the superstars putting them in the right
places
giving them incentive not being greedy
and being humble enough to
to accept that we don't have all the
answers and so
anyways i hope this private conversation
with a billion dollar year revenue
uh this was revenue right what cash
collected per year
uh entrepreneur had to share about his
investments about how he saw business in
general
about how he thought profits were
unnatural i hope you found value in this
because i um
i definitely did and i hope you did the
same so if you like this hit subscribe
and i'll see you next vid bye